Wade is on Facebook Davis there a book
on mutual funds for dummies that you
would recommend you know the best
investment book that we have out is
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book and I
would recommend that to you highly it's
a number one bestseller and it goes into
pretty good detail you can always look
for more but it just depends on how much
you're wanting to comb through the the
process I I do not know of a single book
other than that that goes into the the
absolute nerd level breakdown on mutual
funds to teach the details about it
I will tell you that what I have learned
over the years from having invested for
30 years now 35 years now that the vast
majority of what mutual funds of the
money that you make in mutual funds is
number one because you actually put
money in it there's a lot of people with
a lot of theory there's a lot of people
that sit around talk about stuff over
you know over a cup of coffee and they
have a lot of opinions but they get
paralysis of the analysis and they never
do anything the actual investing of
money is what causes investments to grow
more than anything else the second thing
that I spend the vast majority of my
time other than actually doing it when
it comes to investing is I look at the
rates of return over a long period of
time and you know there's a couple ways
to measure that there's CAGR which is
the compound formula or there's a simple
formula that's just the average annual
return over a period of time and you can
look at the average annual S&P which is
a Standard & Poor 500 if you're buying
good growth stock mutual funds and you
want to beat that you want to buy a fund
that has a higher average annual than
the SP over the given period of time
that you're looking at and so if you've
got a fun that's been open thirty years
as it beat the S&P on average
thirty years and the average annual
return is enough to tell you that and if
you want to compare two funds one
against the other on how they've done in
the same period of time you can compare
it on average annual return and the cagr
is a little bit more sophisticated way
of looking at it but it's irrelevant the
reasons you're relevant the differences
are irrelevant is again if you pick a
fund that's outperformed the S&P and you
actually freaking invest in it that is
enough knowledge right there to cause
you to be a millionaire that's what all
the data tells us and so all this other
hair-splitting and analysis and details
of did the espy average 11.6 and then
the average annual and then the CAG are
is ten point seven yeah or whatever so
what you freaking nerds you get so much
paralysis of the analysis that you
actually do nothing I'm not saying that
is you in particular asking about a book
for dummies that's that's a different
thing but what you have to be aware of
in the open market is the people that
are drawn to the financial services
world are math people they love math I'm
a math person I love math and I caught
myself for many years getting caught up
in over analysis I was spending so much
time analyzing I was doing nothing and
people get paralysis of the analysis and
a lot of people in the financial world
do the same thing and they will spend an
immense amount of their life with their
head stuck up their butt trying to
figure out something it's unbelievable
instead of actually doing it the ones
that we talked to these millionaires on
this millionaire theme hour I'm a
teacher Dave my husband is an engineer
my wife is an engineer and I'm a teacher
and we've invested in our 401 K were you
concerned about the difference between
CAGR and average annual what's that
what's your net worth 4.2 million what's
that what's the difference
they don't even know did you look at the
expense ratios on the mutual fund did
you look at the 12 B 1 fees what's that
they don't even know that 4.2 million
dollars meanwhile mr. Capital nerd over
here with two nickels to rub together
can give you every analyzed breakdown of
everything that's ever happened inside
of a mutual fund and never did anything
and has a hundred thousand dollars to
his freaking name but the guy who just
actually did it and picked decent growth
stock mutual funds that outperform the
S&P which are everywhere by the way
they're the ones that become
millionaires they don't get paralysis of
the analysis so all of that to say I
hadn't really thought about it before
but I probably will never be
recommending a book on the details of a
mutual fund because I don't care and the
data says you shouldn't either
the data points of millionaires not
broke people with analysis skills but
millionaires and for that matter
multimillionaires are people who
actually do something with their money
to invest it to cause it to win and they
have some basic investing tenets that
they use the view CRO will go across the
four types of mutual funds we talk about
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international and you decide
to spread across those four over a
period of thirty years that portfolio of
mutual funds that outperform the S&P
will outperform just being in one type
of fund or just being in one fund or
take out any one of those four and it
will underperform what all four of them
are together we've done the research
we've done the analysis we broke it down
we've had our smart Wester pros look at
it we've gone through it all it's
absolutely there so you don't have to
have a big bunch of detailed analysis on
this now you're welcome to look at it
I'm not saying I'm not trying to hide
anything from you you're welcome to
understand it but my point is
these minutiae money differences in
viewpoints on these things you know
honestly most people don't even think
about whether the mutual fund has a load
or not meaning that they paid a
commission or not and that's a mistake
you should pay a commission on a portion
of your funds because it brings a
quality investment advisor into your
life to walk you through the process and
there's all kinds of data that says of
people that invest on their own with no
load mutual funds have a tendency to
time the market more meaning they try to
jump in when it's hot and jump out when
it's cold and people who time the market
tons of research all kinds of possible
analysis shows that you do not get as a
higher performance as if you just buy
and hold and keep holding and keep
holding and keep holding and keep
holding but it goes down no one gets
hurt on a roller-coaster ride except
those that jump off
I have never divested a single mutual
fund that I own except when it a
underperformed its category over an
extended period of time meaning if I had
a growth stock mutual fund that was
underperforming all other growth stock
mutual funds over an extended period of
time I would move it to a different
growth stock mutual fund or if I was
buying a piece of real estate I have
cashed out some no-load funds that I
bought for that purpose other than that
I've never one time in 35 years moved
money out of the market because I was
scared or into the market because I was
greedy
I just steadily invest steadily invest
steadily invest steadily invest steadily
invest steadily invest and there is
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in there as a result and you can
to the data all shows us that when you
have someone coaching you to keep you
from jumping in and out and to give you
some basic information to keep you
investing in the understanding what
you're investing in someone with the
heart of a teacher like one of our smart
investor pros the data all tells us that
when you stay
in the game you don't jump in and out
you got somebody coaching you to show
you how to pick something that's been
better than the sp500 that's really
about all that matters you state you
start investing you keep investing you
don't quit investing you don't time the
market and you buy funds that I'll
perform the SMP and really if you do
that and you keep doing it for an
extended period of time you'll be a
millionaire or better this is the Dave
Ramsey show